poor Riddick it's like the dude got
demoted it used to be The Chronicles of
him and that was just him just his name
no more Chronicles Riddick
yeah just the name so ridiculous Riddick
movie starring the character Riddick
Riddick is played by Vin Diesel he's
badass he's this killer and glowing eyes
he could see in the dark his eyes glow
in the dark and last time we saw Riddick
he was king of the Necromongers which
are pretty much like space gods and now
they're likely we want to bring Riddick
back down on track you know kind of
pitch black vibe so we find Riddick on
this desolate shitty ass planet
seriously this thing there's nothing
appealing about this planet it's pretty
much Tatooine with clause by clause I
mean a lot of predators which is also
funny because we're where's the prey I
mean this planet is loaded with
predators and things that eat other
animals but they're all predators I'm
just saying there are no bunnies and of
course on this planet there are a couple
of mercenaries that find out Riddick's
there so they go there to take down
Riddick and now we have our Riddick
movie know what we saw in the trailers
that these mercenaries find Riddick and
then these big monsters start invading
their fort and now they have to work
with Riddick to fight off the monsters
you know one of those will there's a
greater evil out there so we got to work
together kind of things not really like
that for most of the movie though which
really wouldn't be a bad thing but I'm
just saying the movie and how it was
written it was a bit messy I really felt
like this movie was three movies in one
I mean there's the first part we're
Riddick's down on this planet and you're
like okay cool he's gonna find out how
to be awesome again you know he's like
I've gotten too soft I need to find the
animal in me again you're like cool
ready get trained right you're still
training man you are still training then
he runs across these mercenaries this is
the coolest part of the movie cuz now
it's a movie about him taking out these
mercenaries like the Batman minus the
bat so he's hiding in the shadows and
he's dragging him off and he's clearly
outsmarting him you're like this is cool
that's what I like about Riddick it's
really what I like about most badasses
that he's just badass but you never find
out how he's badass and all the
chronicles do we ever find out how
Riddick is just so badass we really just
take it as well because he's Riddick
that's always badass it's kinda like how
Batman got into Gotham in Dark Knight
Rises like roses Batman he's not wearing
hockey pads neither is Riddick point is
they're all just awesome and one of them
is really good at ending lives
Katee Sackhoff Senen she's one of the
mercenaries I'm just saying she's all
sexy and [ __ ] seriously she gives you
sexy ass look she likes you
mercenaries can't do that I'm glad they
do if they're you I'm just as they can't
though there is a part of me is like she
looks like she just walked right off the
set of Battlestar Galactica then I
remember Katee Sackhoff on the set of
Battlestar Galactica was a chick I
really wanted to have awesome sex with
so I'm just saying that's not a negative
connotation I'm just saying it needs to
be addressed at least but then when you
finally get to the part that is
ultimately the sales pitch of the movie
which is what the trailer showed you
which is Riddick working with the
mercenaries to take out the big monsters
it's about 20 minutes before the movies
over
seriously 1/6 of the movie is actually
that which isn't a bad thing you know I
hate it when trailers spoil too much of
a movie I'm just saying the road leading
up to that was just kind of shoddy it
was just a bit of a mess there are some
shitty lines of this movie there are
some cheesy ass lines in this movie you
just feel like some of the actors looked
at this script and they were like
director I will toss your salad if I
don't have to read this line Katie did
you say that did you say that between
you and me did you say hey you don't
have to say I'm just saying so there
were some cool stealth kill moments the
kills are really the best part of the
movie were the best parts of the movie I
give the movie credit for wanting to go
back on track to the pitch-black vibe of
the Riddick movies but you feel like the
rewrites and course corrections to get
Riddick back on track to the whole
pitchblack vibe took over half this
movie is it fun it is a fun movie it's a
cool sci-fi ish movie it does have some
cool mercenaries in this movie although
some of the mercenaries have that Alien
Resurrection vibe going on you know
right down to the gimmicks that they
have to have within them I will say if
this movie was a half an hour shorter
and a lot less cheesy would have been
really cool as it stands still a fun
enough sci fi movie if you're drunk and
now there's a party but seriously Katie
sacrum did you say that I really want to
know I saw of the Riddick stories what's
your favorite Riddick story whatever
your favorite is comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you